quelle caisse lourds neufs cool speedo
vous avez entendu leur langage et bien
c'est celui des dicos d'aujourd'hui j'ai
les trois grand larousse achètent un
nouveau robert ça décoiffe enfoncer les
académiciens et depuis longtemps j'ai
dit pourquoi n'avez-vous pas traiter
chiottes d'handi'chiens de l'académie
française puisque vous dites que vous
respectez lusage bah voilà ça c'est du
nuage et il est embarrassé pour répondre
j'ai dit je t'ai timbaut bien français
excellemment forme et vous ne referez
tout de même pas wc3 le petit larousse
illustré 1973 qui paraît aujourd'hui je
peux très bien dire que nous en avons
ras le bol de ce bidule nous sommes trop
transbahuter et préférons être claude ok
n'a en effet pourquoi pas puisque tous
ces mots se trouve depuis aujourd'hui
dans le dictionnaire un énarque
c'est un genre de nuque je n'aime
plaisant à ces dames
c'est un mec qui se prend au sérieux
j'ai fait des yeux comme ça à
l'italienne que pensez-vous des mots
tels que bidule ras-le-bol paumé
barbouzes fayoter du point de vue
littéraire
ce sont des mots ce sont des mots
d'argot d'un emploi d'un emploi
fréquents peux pas vous dire que nous
allons les admettre comme cela il faut
du temps largo est une mode
il y a eu à toutes les époques des mots
qui sont apparues et qui ont disparu
le l'académie attend de voir justement
si un mot ce matière et s'il correspond
à une nécessité à une réalité dans
l'angle bientôt l'an 2000 et déjà les
dictionnaires prennent acte des
nouvelles technologies de leur
vocabulaire
parmi les nouveaux mots qui font leur
apparition cette année à terme
[Musique]
en termes si c'est un navigateur sur
internet je m'avoue gagner et pour les
internautes avertis la meilleure façon
de communiquer selim el les
dictionnaires 2003 2004 et c'est
l'occasion comme chaque année de prendre
le pouls de l'évolution de la langue
française avec ces nouveaux mots cette
année par exemple tolérance zéro people
un mot anglais ou encore télé réalité
comprend des mots comme pacs comme rtt
ou comme trithérapies qui corresponde à
une réalité qu'il faut absolument faire
entrer dans le dictionnaire parce que
sinon elle ce sont des cycles très
courants ou des mots très courant que
l'utilisateur doit doit connaître on le
fait entrer beaucoup plus directement en
l'espace de deux ans la rave party est
une fête nocturne dédié à la danse et à
la musique techno l'actualité cette
année fait entrer pêle-mêle dans les
dictionnaires les pitbulls les sans
papiers la maladie de la vache folle et
le train pendulaire la cuvée 98 accorde
beaucoup d'importance à notre nouveau
vocabulaire quotidien une certaine façon
de parler
bref écoutez bien si vous êtes cassé ou
destroy vous pouvez halluciné vous
prendre pour un nain de jardin et le cas
échéant faire un caca nerveux
[Musique]